brace yourselves this is the last
preview breakdown of the season I know I
know everyone let out your frustration
but we're gonna try and make the best of
it figuring out what exactly we can
expect next episode for those of you new
here this is a full spoiler video where
nothing is off limits even feet stuff so
let's jump into it well well well if it
isn't rainis writing Bay Leafs to the
east try saying that five times fast
after her epic escape from the dragon
pit rhaenice has made her way across
Blackwater Bay towards Dragonstone no
doubt to be the first person to tell
renera that the greens have usurped the
throne remember that the events of
episode 9 basically take place over two
days so rhaenyra wouldn't have even
heard of her father's passing yet I'm
curious if we'll get any further insight
into why rhaenis decided to spare the
greens she could have ordered me at
least to burn them all in one Fell Swoop
saving tens of thousands of lives that
will die as a result of the Civil War in
episode 9's Inside the episode video
showrunners Ryan Ryan kondel and Miguel
sapochnik State rhenice didn't kill them
because of her moral standpoint this is
one mother looking upon another mother
doing what she needs to to protect her
son and renice just doesn't have it in
her you can let me know in the comments
whether you agree with her decision or
not at Dragonstone rhaenis warns
rhaenyra that the greens are coming for
her also I just want to say I love her
badass armor rhaenyra wears a black
dress fitting since the episode is
called The Black Queen by her side is
husband Damon Targaryen holding on to
his Blade Dark sister House Targaryen
has two ancestral blades Dark sister and
Blackfire so it's a great juxtaposition
to see one in the hands of Damon and the
other in aegons rather subtle is
rhaenyra holding her stomach as she
hears the news not only does she have to
deal with the prospect of Bloodshed but
she's also pregnant with her and Damon's
third child I wonder if rhenice will
tell rhaenyra about this infighting
between Allison and Otto we know that
Otto wants rhaenyra kill while Alison at
least wants to offer her terms of Peace
on Dragonstone it looks like Damon and
raniera have a serious discussion about
whether or not to bend the knee in the
book Rainier is offered full control of
Dragonstone and driftmark in exchange
for swearing fealty to the king but
there's something far more powerful at
play here not only is aegon II going to
be a terrible King but rhaenyra has a
sacred Duty she alone knows of aegon the
conqueror's prophecy something passed
down from ruler to ruler it is her duty
to make sure she is Queen so she can
protect the realm from this upcoming
evil a shot of Prince eamond about to
take off his eye patch in the book it is
said he'd often put a sapphire in its
socket so I wonder if we'll be seeing
that here a sapphire is also what's on
his emblem in the intro credits we can
match up the background here with that
of Storm's end the seat of house
Baratheon we saw in episode 4. in last
episode's green council meeting there
was a brief talk about arranging a
marriage between one of Allison's boys
and the baratheons you might recall
Borman Baratheon helped rhaenyra in her
quest for a husband however he passed
away sometime after episode 5 leaving
his son boros in charge boros has four
daughters and it looks as though Eamonn
will get his pick of which one to Wed
that is if boros agrees remember that
Eamon does not see marriage as this
emotional bond rather a duty in episode
7 he told aegon that if he had to wet
his own sister he would do it without
question if it strengthened the family
so Eamonn as being the good little
soldier here and does what he's told now
a lot of [ __ ] goes down here at Storm's
end one of boros's daughters MOX Eamonn
asking him if Luke not only removed his
eye but also his balls and to add to the
drama guess who shows up at the same
time Luke the guy who cut out his eye
renira sent him to stormzen thinking it
would be fairly safe she's always had a
good relationship with the baratheons
boros even offers Luke his choice of
daughter to Wed but he he's already
betrothed to Reina as Luke makes his way
back from Storm's end a terrible storm
rages he gets on his Dragon Eric's but
is attacked by Eamonn on vegar normally
Eric's could have outflown the much
larger and slower Dragon but the weather
impeded him and thus both Erics and
luceris are killed Luke's body washes
ashore three days later Luke's death
prompts demon to send the assassin's
blood and cheese to kill one of aegon's
sons as Revenge this might be what
Helena prophesized as the Beast beneath
the boards as the Assassins used the
keeps underground passageways to gain
access to her Chambers and kill her son
jaharas however the Beast beneath the
boards could simply be a reference to
melees literally breaking through the
ground at the dragon pit back at
Dragonstone reniera has assembled the
black Council basically her version of
the small Council in attendance are at
least two members of the kingsguard sir
Stefan darklin and Lawrence marbrand
maester gerardus is here and this is the
only guy I couldn't figure out if her
are going by the book he's one of the
five lesser Lords either celtagar of
claw Island Staunton of rook's rest
Massey of stone dance bar Emin of sharp
point or darkland of Dusk and Dale not
seen as Rainier's biggest Ally Corliss
Valerian who is likely still Gravely
injured and recovering at driftmark
although in the book he is in this
meeting aegon the conquerors painted
table which he used in his conquest of
Westeros is lit by fire or flame
underneath we see a peace move atop
Winterfell this is where Jace will be
sent to gain Lord kriegen Stark's
allyship and the two houses sign an
agreement known as The Pact of Ice and
Fire it proclaims that Lord kriegen's
son ricken who's only one year old at
the time would marry Jason bayla's
firstborn daughter when and if they have
one we see a bunch of Swords gathered at
the meeting of the black council with an
argument being put forward that they
should lay Siege to the red keep this is
foolish neither side has enough strength
to take either King's Landing or
Dragonstone directly so Jace speaking on
behalf of his brother and their
betrothed volunteers to ride forth and
gain more allies with him allegedly
saying dragons will win the Lord's over
quicker than Ravens I'm not exactly sure
what Reina is going to do considering
she still doesn't have a dragon although
Damon did find a clutch of cyrax's eggs
one of which will hatch and become a
dragon known as morning who Reina will
eventually claim here's a shot of Luke
grabbing his sword hilt likely at
Storm's end when he's confronted by
aemond fun fact he swore to his mother
he would not engage in any fighting here
at storm Zen we get to see just how
massive vegar is along the castle walls
Sir Eric Cargill has arrived pledging
his fealty to rhaenyra offering her
father's Crown the last we saw this
Crown was atop viserys's dead body so it
looks like Eric grabbed it and put it in
that Satchel we saw him carry while
escaping with renice another epic shot
of Luke traversing this storm where
he'll eventually be killed by aemond in
Vegas now in the closed captioning we
can see an unnamed speaker say your
cause holds a power that has not been
seen since the days of old valyria what
exactly is this power he speaks of and
could it be magic that's one thing that
really hasn't been seen since those old
days a quick shot of a pensive renera
with Damon in the foreground speaking of
Damon we see him likely somewhere on
Dragonstone singing in high Valerian to
a dragon I've heard that none of the
wild dragons of Dragonstone will be seen
this season so that leaves out this
dragon from being the notorious cannibal
so my bet is that this is vermouth or
who was last ridden by King jaharis in
the reflection of this dragon's eye we
can see what looks to be demon reaching
to touch him outside of Dragonstone
Three Dragons make their way likely Jace
Luke and Bala who have gone to seek
allies I thought this shot was really
interesting vermouthor burns the roof of
this cave is he merely displaying his
anger or is this something Damon wanted
him to do and if it was something Damon
wanted was it to Mine Dragon glass or
expand the Cave System my mind is
spinning with questions about why Damon
would be risking his life being so close
to a wild Dragon Damon takes out his
sword as Otto arrives with the
conditions of Peace conditions which
means swearing fealty to King aegon no
wonder Damon drew his sword we can also
make up renira now with her own Crown
reading these terms from a parchment
you'll also see Grand maester Orwell off
to the side in the book it was Orwell
who delivered these terms and when
renera questions him what he sided with
the usurper she has his chain of office
strip from his body and given to maester
gerardus letting Orwell and his men
leave with their lives I also just like
how this shot here mimics the same
confrontation between Damon and Otto in
episode 2 and last but not least we have
vegar chomping his way through the Skies
of Storms and likely trying to take a
big chunk out of Luke and Eric's but now
I want to hear what you think will
happen in the season finale let me know
in the comments below thanks for
watching and be sure to like And
subscribe every little bit
the channel out for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstory YT until next time
remember